Sharpen your axes, because it's time to return
to the age of "Vikings." The second season of
"Vikings: Valhalla" is cresting the horizon,
and we'd all better be prepared for its attack.
It seemed "Vikings" was at an end when the
original History series concluded in 2020.
But it wasn't long before the show's creator,
Michael Hirst, passed the torch to Jeb Stuart,
who crossed the streaming seas to Netflix
and gave us "Vikings: Valhalla," a sequel
series set a century after the events of its
predecessor. "Valhalla" introduced fans to
Prince Harald of Norway and hero-in-the-making
Leif Erikson. Initially wary of one another,
the two became allies to change
the time of the Vikings forever.
Of course, they've still got to overcome
some obstacles to get there. The first
season ended with Leif seeing red and
Harald on the run after Kattegat's fall,
so their combined comeback will need to be epic.
"Freydis, it's over."
Netflix offered up a first look at "Vikings:
Valhalla" Season 2 during the streamer's annual
TUDUM event. Starting shortly after the
events of the first season, Harald, Leif,
and Freydis are on the run, only for Olaf to
push them back to the shoreline. Thankfully,
help comes from above via an unknown ally. Is
Forkbeard fending for our heroes, or has his
son King Canute turned up at the right time?
Whoever it is, they make an explosive impact.
The second season will debut on January 12, 2023,
but Netflix hasn't released any other trailers,
keeping things close to the vest. The
first-season trailers hit only a few
short weeks before the season was released,
so the streamer seems to be taking that
approach again. TUDUM did offer up this
brief synopsis of the season, though:
"Season 2 finds our heroes shortly
after the tragic fall of Kattegat,
an event that has shattered their
dreams and altered their destinies.
Finding themselves suddenly
fugitives in Scandinavia,
they are forced to test their ambitions and
courage in worlds beyond their familiar fjords."
Showrunner Jeb Stuart further explained
to TUDUM that Harald and Leif will be
traveling down the Dnieper River,
in an adventure he describes as
similar to "Thelma and Louise," while
Freydís will be heading to the Baltic
area of Pomerania. Stuart also promised
quite an array of characters, adding,
"We put together this motley crew of nobles,
Muslim astronomers and con men,
and they shove off from Novgorod."
Leo Suter and Sam Corlett will return to lay
waste to their enemies as Prince Harald and
Leif Erikson, respectively, along with Frida
Gustavsson as Freydís Eiríksdóttir , Leif's
sister. The latter has a crucial path of
her own as the last daughter of Uppsala.
Beyond that talented trifecta, the show will also
see the return of Jóhannes Haukur Jóhannesson
as the side-switching contender for the throne,
Olaf. Last seen threatening Kattegat and sending
its protectors running, Olaf's victory
was short-lived. King Canute's father,
King Sweyn Forkbeard, approached with a fleet of
ships to bring down the treacherous tyrant. Expect
all three to be returning for Season 2, along
with the surprise return of Caroline Henderson,
who played Kattegat's fallen ruler, Jarl Haakon.
Speaking to Metro about her character's demise,
the Swedish star quipped about whether
she was totally gone from the series,
"We don't really know that. She might
turn up as a ghost or something."
If that's not enough, "Valhalla" will
also see the arrival of an MCU star
and a previous punching bag for boxing champ
Adonis Creed. Florian Munteanu of "Shang-Chi"
and "Creed II" fame will play the part
of Byzantine general George Maniakes.
Bradley James of "Merlin" will play the
leader of a particularly pagan bunch of
warriors. Hayat Kamille, Marcin Dorocinski,
and Sofya Lebedeva have also joined the cast.
In an interview with Digital Spy in
February 2022, Jeb Stuart revealed that
even before the first season's release,
the second was well into development,
and he was "dying to get it out there."
Even before swords were drawn for the first
season of "Valhalla," Netflix had given the
green light for a massive 24-episode order,
assuring that we'd be seeing Leif and
Harald for at least three seasons.